beautiful do we do a live podcast with
listen to me
from Jeffrey Epstein's like New York
City town house like outside of it do I
fly Seoul to New York and we just sit
outside of Jeffrey Epstein's townhouse
yeah why not we get removed probably you
know I wanted to do one by at Camp hero
and Montauk by the stranger things but
also [ __ ] stranger things I've had
enough of that yeah hey enough of that
are like older now hey enough enough
no one cares stop with this nostalgia
you're all like some odd nostalgia hi
yep for the 80s even Spielberg [ __ ] you
know that you know the 80s was uh AIDS
and crack for a lot of people I know you
lily-white [ __ ] think the 80s was all
about malls and carnivals but for a lot
of people the AIDS was about watching
your friend waste away because he had a
disease the government wouldn't say is
true or watching mom light a rock in
your living room cuz the CIA was selling
it to her I want to see that stranger
things episode where's the stranger
things episode where Wynonna riders
smoking crack and she doesn't give a
[ __ ] about the demagogue on anymore yeah
she doesn't care about the alien she's
like will you kids shut the [ __ ] up
about this alien and she just smacks
them right across the face and she just
lights a rock where's that episode
wisdom wheel where's the Savings and
Loan scandal where they all lose their
[ __ ] houses and Wynonna riders
[ __ ] smoking crack in a car that
they're all living in hopper hopper has
AIDS cuz he's sucking [ __ ] and not
telling anyone about it
he's a leather daddy he's doing
intravenous drugs
let's get nostalgic for real [ __ ] okay
it's not all hanging out in the mall and
fighting some alien yeah okay [ __ ]
clowns make a real show about crack and
AIDS kiddies
yeah show that come with some fun music
behind people doing blow yeah Wynonna
rider would have been sniffing her
[ __ ] face off in that kitchen numb
mouth barely speak shana the kids like
mom what happened to my piggy bank shut
up I'm going out mom's going out she
joins the Dallas buyers club soon
Wolford that character turns around to
the other kid he's like mom smoking it
now it's getting bad it's getting bad
she doesn't have any money anymore so
she's smoking it that should be the
alien Wynonna rider by the way before
she got stranger things with shoplifting
right she was stealing [ __ ] from [ __ ]
Bloomingdale's yeah I don't like that
show I mean listen it's one of those
things where it should have been a movie
90-minute movie
I enjoyed it when it first came on we
don't need nine seasons of everything we
don't need to see these kids but grow up
to be in their 30s no one gives a [ __ ]
okay you still fighting the same alien
and not for ready the upside down what
is the upside down you know I don't I
watched the first season that was a like
the wall was like the monster or
something like right it's based on the
monster project it's based on something
that actually happened and I you know I
get it but again we don't you know pair
base it on by the way marlboro lights
sponsored the show um marlboro lights do
not just for substitute teachers who
want to die you ever seen your sub
smoking I used to do coke of my sub my
sub was a real Italian real [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] and she used to do we used to come
over to coke house and get a couple of
bags her and her husband used to
probably load up and [ __ ] each other
like like animals then she'd come in the
next day with fifteen circles under her
eyes look like a raccoon drinking coffee
to put on a video and go sit in the back
she was still coming down she was a good
woman
I miss her I miss those people